До побачення в Верховній Раді бачимо
найгірші практики часів Януковича
узурпувати владу в країні нема чого
ховатися друзі Всіх вітаю Отже
розпочалася нова Парламентська сесія
11-ту сесію Верховної Ради України
деятого скликання та її пленарне
засідання Верховної Ради України
Оголошую відкритим На жаль немає
журналістів в Верховній Раді України так
і не допустили їх висвітлювати
діяльність депутатів Тому ми вимагаємо
по-перше повернути журналістів в кулуари
Верховної Ради по-друге відновити пряму
трансляцію засідань нема чого ховатися
тому підписуйтесь на наш YouTube канал
дивіться наші соцмережі тут про роботу
Верховної Ради
України уряд з'явився буквально на
хвилини аби разом виконати гімн в
засіданні Верховної Ради беруть участь
прем'єр-міністр України Денис
Анатолійович шмигаль а також члени
Кабінету Міністрів України
знінеться
доля давайте подякуємо прем'єр-міністру
України Денис шмихалю та членам Кабінету
Міністрів України за участь у пленарному
засіданні До нас прийшов уряд тільки
заспівати гімн До побачення в Верховній
Раді хор вірьовки своє заспівав ми пішли
за стефанчука у нас давно немає годин
запитань до уряду Ну і на жаль парламент
втрачає свої контролюючі функції над
виконавчою Гіл влади в останній уряд Ми
бачили з вами у вересні минулого року і
сьогодні європейська Солідарність
говорила про неприпустимість
авторитарних тенденцій в державі і ми
бачимо найгірші практики часів Януковича
На жаль стефанчука і ко тичуть носом те
що відбувається в парламенті вже з
брюсселю це план Ukraine facility п'ята
стаття говорить про те що передумовою
для видання Україні надання нам допомоги
50 РД євро є демократія є Парламентська
багатопартійність До речі чи не вперше
про загрози демократії говорить не лише
наша фракція останнім часом ці укази і
цей стан воєнний він використовується
для того щоб а узурпувати владу в країні
і це дуже неправильно найважливішими
голосуваннями першого пленарного дня
лютого безумовно стали мобілізаційні
закони пекої Солідарності в дев'яте
Одноголосно підтримує рішення про
продовження воєнного стану і мобілізації
як проекти які подані верховним
головнокомандувачем Відповідно до
Конституції України але що примітно
попри те що саме президент відповідає за
мобілізацію І от вносить закони просто
які вводять дії воєнного стану чи
продовжують мобілізацію президент
Зеленський як верховний
головнокомандувач повністю самоусунувся
від зміни мобілізаційного закону ми
готові працювати зі змінами які
запропонує президент а не з тим мотлахом
яка нашкрябала одіозна депутатка За
завданням офісу президента і потім
соромно дивитися в очі і військовим і
цивільно до парламенту зайшов черговий
Урядовий законопроект який мало
відрізняється від попереднього цей
законопроект містить корупційні ризики
крім того є звернення до нас
парламентарів від європейської
бізнес-асоціації що ця редакція
законопроекту потребує доопрацювання і
не може бути ухвалена в такому вигляді
там є порушення прав людини є і
блокування рахунків і заборона на
консульські послуги питання А де
демобілізація не може бути мобілізації
без демобілізації ці підрозділи ті воїни
які більше двох років знаходяться на
першій лінії в най складніших напрямках
фронту не зможуть Навіть через 36
місяців війни отримати право на
демобілізацію не може бути так що вхід
на військову службу є а виходу немає а
вихід тільки не дай босподи двосом чи
важким трьохсотим і це є ключова
претензія нашої політичної сили до цього
закону зверніть увагу от як відбувається
засідання в парламенті ходять Бродять
щось говорять нікому нічого не цікаво
перекривають своїми спинами виступи
опозиції і головуючому все одно і
стефанчук і Корнієнко Ну вони тільки
можуть знаєте там тюкати опозицію
найбільше вони не здатні навіть на те
аби нормально організувати роботу
Верховної Ради України такого бардака
ніколи не було в парламенті з першого по
девяте скликання тільки зараз можна собі
дозволити абсолютно безвідповідально
ставитися до обговорення законопроектів
і поправок На жаль в порядку денному
першого дня сесії стояло кілька
лобійських і законів з корупційними
ризиками серед тих поправок які напхали
сюди до другого читання десятки
корупційних поправок безконтрольно
абсолютно під час воєнного стану
передавати землі сільськогосподарського
призначення там під промисловість під
виробництво начебто для дерегуляції без
документів із абсолютно без документів і
без дозволів Відведення землі на
річках як винищення лісів і розміщення
там різного роду рекреаційних комплексів
в цьому законі ми бачимо стільки ризиків
але чомусь наша відбудова відбудовується
не там де вона потрібна не там де люди
втратили житло не вони у нас
відбуваються не знаю в лісах на річках
на озерах І от завжди важливо дивитися
хто голосує за такі закони А якщо слуги
разом з опзж і групами олігархічними то
все зрозуміло ну і з важливого ми
прийняли рішення про запрошення до зали
Голови служби безпеки України пана
малюка я виношу на процедурне
голосування виклик Голови служби безпеки
СБУ пана малюка з доповіддю аби він
розповів депутатам про незаконне
стеження за журналістами очевидно що це
є грандіозний скандал який продовжує
авторитарні тенденції в Україні тиск на
медіа тиск на опозицію Дякую всім хто
голосував Да ми маємо разом захищати
свободу слова це засадничі принципи Я
хочу нагадати головуючому на засіданні
що зараз має стояти в порядку денному
кадрове рішення під час погоджувальної
ради ми домовилися нарешті винести в
порядок денний постанову про відкликання
пані безуглої з посади заступниці голови
комітету нацбезпеки і оборони прошимо
дотримуватися домовленостей і рішень
погоджувальної ради І зараз поставити цю
Постанову
ще раз переконалися що шулерами якими є
керівництво парламенту і фракція
монобільшості немає про що говорити
персонажів які щодня накидають на
військових ображають військових
ображають пам'ять загиблих це для
банкової безцінні персонажі і тому
безугла залишається в нас в комітеті
нацбезпеки Мені соромно зараз
констатувати що керівники вашої фракції
вони не спроможні тримати слово як і
керівництво парламенту Після кількох
голосува
зокрема щодо продовження дії воєнного
стану і продовження мобілізації слуги
перевтомилися потенціал зали закінчився
ну Подивіться Уже немає нікого в
сесійній залі розбіглися Парламентська
зала завжди повна Ну і отак от працює
зараз цей Парламент просто соромно в що
він перетворився попри все ми будемо
захищати демократію захищати
парламентаризм друзі підписуйтесь на мій
YouTube канал дивіться наші соцмережі
розумію що парламенту немає в Марафоні
немає на телеканалі рада тому ми
розповідаємо про те що відбувається в
Верховній Раді України залишайтеся з
нами все буде Україна друзі